You ready?
Get ready.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
NARRATOR: Barbara
Bollard-Breen and her team
are here to create
a virtual version
of a historic hut
that's over 100 years
old, in order to
help protect it.
Here we go.
NARRATOR: And she's about to
step inside for the first time.
Oh my god.
Wow.
I don't even know what
I was expecting, but--
It's so beautifully preserved.
It's unbelievable.
And this is how
they left it when
they headed out to the pole.
It's as if
they're just waiting
for everyone to come back.
NARRATOR: On October 24, 1911,
British explorer Robert Falcon
Scott and 16 men left
this hut on an expedition
to the South Pole.
They were the second group
ever to make it there,
but on their way back they
were caught in a blizzard
that lasted nine days.
On March 29th, Scott
wrote in his journal,
"We shall stick
it out to the end,
but we are getting
weaker, of course,
and the end cannot be far.
It seems a pity, but I do
not think I can write more."
Months later, the
party was found
frozen to death, over
100 miles from the safety
of this shelter.
Amazing.
It's stunning.
It's preserved so well, I feel
like we're the first people
to discover it.
God, everywhere
you look, there
is just something unbelievable.
The boots, and
hats on the shelves.
It's amazing.
You can almost feel their
presence here, can't you?
You can.
You can just imagine it
with people in the bunks.
Sitting around the
table, sharing a meal.
Working in the kitchen.
The dishes are there!
Sugar, cocoa.
Oh my god.
the Illustrated London News.
Saturday, February 29th, 1908.
Wow.
It cost sixpence.
Isn't that something?
NARRATOR: The hut is
25 feet by 50 feet,
and Barbara's team has
just a few hours inside it
to complete their mission.
Time to get to work.
How about you go down the
center, I'll comb this way,
and see how we go?
OK.
We're making a virtual
reality mosaic of the inside
of this hut by having multiple
cameras at multiple angles,
and multiple heights.
When we process them
on a computer later,
we can get a 3D
image of the hut.
We take thousands
of images, and then I
stitch those images together
to create 3D orthomosaics.
We actually have to
make every second count,
because we've only got a
limited amount of time here.
It's a very remote location.
We've got one shot at this,
so it's a little bit nerve
wracking, but we want to
do it right, because we
can't come back again.